on this friday night a word of caution
for the holiday weekend a warning to
keep your thanksgiving circle small as
the fourth wave shows some signs of
slowing down we're not getting together
with anybody who's not fully vaccinated
and the cross border road blocks for
travelers with mixed vaccine doses
that's detrimental to our business
that's detrimental to our way of life
record-setting gas prices gases going up
the foods is going up with our life is
going up
everything is going up what's driving up
the costs no vaccine no transplant a
colorado kidney patient told to get the
shot or give up on a life-saving surgery
plus giving thanks to canada's frontline
health workers
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sophie louie good
evening and thanks for joining us on
this thanksgiving weekend there is a bit
of good news on the pandemic but
canada's public health officials warn
we're not out of the woods yet new
modeling shows the national r number the
reproduction rate has fallen below one
for the first time since mid-july
meaning the pandemic has dropped out of
a growth pattern but severe illness is
still elevated across the country
primarily among the unvaccinated the
latest data shows the average weekly
case count is 10 times higher in
unvaccinated canadians than those who
are fully vaccinated hospitalizations
are 36 times higher in unvaccinated
patients canada's top doctor says basic
and essential cautions are still needed
to see us through the respiratory
illness season ahead and whether
vaccinated or not canadians need to
remain vigilant this long weekend raquel
fletcher has our top story tonight
for the second pandemic thanksgiving
canadians hosting family and friends
this weekend will once again have to
limit the guest list my family is all
kind of a little confused right now i
have two siblings that are in nova
scotia so i don't think i'll be able to
see them now we're not getting together
with anybody who's not fully vaccinated
as we head into thanksgiving weekend
canadians are being urged to keep
gatherings small canada's chief public
health officer says this is particularly
important if you live in the middle of
the country
official rules for indoor gatherings
vary from province to province in bc and
the northwest territories restrictions
are limited to vulnerable regions yukon
and newfoundland and labrador recommend
limiting celebrations to close friends
and family and several provinces cap
gathering sizes at under 30. and in
manitoba festivities with unvaccinated
people are limited to just two
households the strictest rules are in
new brunswick immediate households only
and in alberta 10 vaccinated people can
get together but the unvaccinated are
prohibited from gathering at all in
saskatchewan 69 percent of people have
received at least one dose the lowest
vaccination rate among the provinces but
it is not restricting the number of
people at private gatherings this
weekend at all
one icu doctor in saskatoon says he
cannot stress how disappointed he is in
the government and says saskatchewan
people don't know how bad things really
are we are unable to operate on uh their
loved ones and save their lives when it
comes to their surgeries and procedures
i'm not sure he's explaining to the
people that we have put a significant
portion of patients chemotherapy on hold
dr massry says doctors are already
having to decide who gets an icu bed and
who doesn't even if there are no
official restrictions he's urging people
gathering this weekend to only do so if
they are vaccinated and to hold all
activities outside
raquel fletcher global news ottawa well
this is also the time of year when
people start planning their winter
getaways to sunny destinations but as
mike lucato reports there may be limits
on where you can go depending on which
vaccines you've received
there are many other countries that are
still not available like many people
sousa jovanovic had big plans to travel
but kovit 19 got in the way she booked a
trip to italy not only because it's a
nice place to visit but unlike other
countries italy allows travelers who
mixed doses of different vaccines like
jovanovic and her husband there's one
problem the couple need to travel to the
u.s which come november may not allow
travelers who mixed vaccines we won't be
able to as far as the rules are right
now
that that's detrimental to our business
that's detrimental to our way of life
that's even more upsetting because she
followed public health guidelines to
take the first dose of vaccine offered
to her she's not alone nearly four
million canadians were given a
combination of viral vector and mrna
vaccine or
two different mrna shots despite the
presence of the game-changing delta
variant at a virtual press conference
friday canada's top doctor said health
canada officials have been talking to
their american counterparts about the
efficacy and safety of mixed dosing
let's just say we have left no stones
unturned to advocate
for the vaccine schedules here
the u.s is expected to establish vaccine
requirements for travelers by november
while snowbirds and sun weary canadians
want to book travel now in an interview
set to air sunday on the west block
health minister patty haydew said it's
still not a good time to leave the
country some canadians even want to
travel because they haven't seen family
in a very long time that we still have
travel advisories in place recommending
that people don't travel unless it's
absolutely necessary jovanovic says it
is necessary for her business and she
hopes ontario will follow other
provinces and offer her a third and
matching dose of vaccine so that she can
travel
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
well while the fourth wave is slowing
down in some parts of the country it's
still surging in others the northwest
territories is dealing with record case
numbers despite a high rate of
vaccination across canada the territory
has the highest rate of active cases
more than double that of alberta the
delta variant is spreading faster than
ever even though 79 percent of residents
are now fully vaccinated
this variant and
likely variants to come
will find those pockets of vulnerable
people
we had a relatively high rate of
vaccination but nevertheless some
pockets of vulnerability that were that
were that were remaining and
what we saw is that the virus took hold
within those pockets and has continued
to spread again primarily amongst the
people who are unvaccinated
and you can read more about why covet 19
is spreading so rapidly in the northwest
territories on our website global news
dot ca slash global national
a colorado woman's decision not to get
vaccinated against covet 19 may cost her
her life but not from the virus she has
kidney disease and needs a transplant
her friend has offered one of her
kidneys but the colorado transplant
center won't do the operation unless
both women get their shots jennifer
johnson reports
leilani lutali's life is on the line
standing in the way her religious
beliefs against the coven 19 vaccine
lutali has stage five renal disease and
has a kidney donor but the colorado
hospital slated to do the transplant
won't operate until both she and her
donor get vaccinated i found myself i
think trying to understand where the
hippocratic oath comes in to play here
about do no harm lutali is a born-again
christian who refuses to get vaccinated
because of the role stem cells played in
the development of the vaccines she met
her organ donor at bible study who is
also unwilling to get vaccinated if i'm
the one and i can't give her my kidney
essentially i'm
also now condemning my friend to death
you know because i can't get the vaccine
university of colorado health sent
lutaly a letter writing you will have 30
days to begin the vaccination series if
your decision is to refuse covet
vaccination you will be removed from the
kidney transplant list the risk of death
for example if a transplant patient gets
coveted is about two to five times
greater than in the general population
uc health has long required other
vaccines including the measles mumps and
rubella shot for transplants other organ
transplant centers are making similar
decisions or putting recipients who
won't get vaccinated low priority on
crowded transplant lists but lutali
isn't backing down i'm being coerced
into
making a decision that
is one i'm not comfortable making right
now in order to live loutali and her
donor are now looking at hospitals in
other states that will perform her
life-saving surgery including florida
and texas which have banned many cobia
19 rules and mandates
jennifer johnson global news washington
well some good news on canada's economic
front employment numbers are now back to
pre-pandemic levels statistics canada
says there were 157 000 new jobs added
across the country last month that
pushed the unemployment rate down to 6.9
percent the lowest it's been since the
pandemic began however the total number
of hours worked is still 1.5 percent
below pre-pandemic levels
as more people return to work and the
economy gets back on its feet the demand
for gasoline is now growing prices are
breaking records in several places
across the country and it's expected to
get worse as we head into winter mike
drewlay explains what's fueling the
sudden spike
there's a certain defeatism when filling
up at the pump i need to get to work so
i don't really have much of a choice in
montreal prices edged past a dollar
fifty a liter a record no one wants to
see broken if the gas is going up is our
foods is going up as our life is going
up
everything is going up sadly he's right
and what's more there doesn't appear to
be any relief in sight which means if
you don't like here in montreal a dollar
fifty liter you're not gonna like a
dollar sixty liter which is what we're
going to achieve one way or another well
before christmas with fewer people
driving due to the pandemic in 2020 gas
prices dipped dramatically but everybody
knew that was temporary and they've
since climbed to a record average of
1.46 a liter the why is a bit more
complicated although it starts with
crude prices demand was so low in april
2020 oil was somehow selling for below
zero dollars today demand has seen crude
surge to a seven year high
oil production is also down
significantly in part because of the
shift to green energy and that wouldn't
be a factor but only 4.6 percent of
vehicle sales in canada are zero
emission so fuel remains an essential
need
overseas the situation is actually worse
gas stations in the uk are running out
of fuel and europe's energy costs
continue to rise as the temperature dips
because norway and russia aren't
exporting as much natural gas
what this really means is that we're in
for a long period of
of
an energy super bubble if you will
something we haven't seen since 2008
where price
continues to rise no matter what the
economic circumstances are so get ready
for a cold expensive winter mike trolley
global news toronto
journalists awarded a nobel prize coming
up why their efforts to promote free
independent and fact-based journalism
are critical for peace
plus afghan women fight to keep rights
they gained in america's longest war
this year's nobel peace prize has been
awarded to two journalists for their
fight for freedom of expression both are
from countries where free speech and
criticism of the government often lead
to harsh punishment according to the
organization reporters without borders
so far this year 24 journalists have
been killed and
350 have been jailed directly due to
their work eric sorensen has more on the
winners and the rule an independent
press plays in promoting peace
dmitry muratov's reaction to winning the
nobel prize it's not really for him
he named six colleagues anna politkovsky
was one of several journalists killed
reporting for muratov's novaya gazetta
renowned for its independence covering
russian politics a precarious profession
in the time of vladimir putin
maria ressa founded online news site
rappler and has faced arrest and
harassment reporting on death squads and
controversies around president rodrigo
duterte of the philippines the nobel
committee recognized their efforts to
safeguard freedom of speech ms ressa and
mr muratov
are receiving the peace prize
for their courageous fight
for freedom of expression in the
philippines
and in russia maria ressa too recognized
the courage of others thank you to the
nobel peace prize committee for
for um
recognizing
what we're going through these are
people who are really courageous
journalists all around the world are
under threat
under attack by increasingly
authoritarian regimes regimes that
increasingly target journalists even
democracies can become more
authoritarian we are not going to let
the fake news tell us what to do in
canada we may sometimes take our
democratic rights for granted i just
telephoned stephen harper and i've
offered him my congratulations the
peaceful transfer of power from one
election to the next canadians have
accepted a liberal have neglected a
liberal government a result we accept
without hesitation does your party
suddenly have higher standards overnight
no here the most powerful politicians
can be challenged without fear this
won't become another one of your broken
promises what we've done but around the
world for too many journalists reporting
facts and seeking truth comes with
personal risk one of maria ressa's
colleagues also arrested feels validated
so it is so important that we receive
this price well just maria but it's an
affirmation for journalists all over the
world from a journalist at novaya
gazetta today a simple hurrah
another said the nobel prize proves that
what we do is not in vain erik sorensen
global news toronto
to another fight for facts google is
planning to restrict ads and content
that promote false claims about climate
change the company says the goal is to
stop the spread and monetization of
misinformation google plans to roll out
the policy in the next two months it
will also apply to youtube which just
announced a crackdown on vaccine
misinformation
still ahead afghan women mourn decades
of progress as it quickly fades under
the taliban
in the weeks since u.s forces left
afghanistan ending america's longest war
one question remains if the taliban is
back in control exactly what was
accomplished for this week's the new
reality mike armstrong looks at what the
20-year mission left behind in
afghanistan and whether its legacy will
last
i wish it was just a nightmare it has
been two months of wishing she could
wake up from a bad dream chakriya barak
zai was a member of the afghan
government when the taliban took over
kabul she knew she'd be a target she
escaped narrowly
looking back in the last 20 years
barak's eye says it was a window of
opportunity and freedom for women it was
a time of blossom for us it was a time
for us to explore
now the taliban has promised a more
moderate government this time around but
it seems to have brought much of its old
brutality back it is again using fear as
a tool
i don't know why people are asking oh we
should give them time we should give
them time till they destroy everything
and kill everyone the taliban's first
reign over afghanistan turned the
country into what some have called an
open-air prison women were basically
banned from public life hidden behind
burqas few worked they barely left their
homes and there was no education nobody
deserves such a kind of life this young
woman never knew that world until now
we're calling her leda to protect her
identity she grew up able to go to
school worked as a photographer and
traveled
not anymore the only job that i have is
sitting at home and crying for
all the things which i lost not only me
all afghan people this is new
afghanistan barack said says the country
the taliban now controls has changed a
new generation grew up knowing freedoms
and going to school
the protests in the early weeks after
the taliban returned showed the
difference
they want
peace
they want
dignity they want to be counted as a
human barak zai says technology is
making it harder for the taliban to keep
its brutality from getting out
she also has a theory that where there
is oppression and pressure there is
resistance and that with this new
generation
that resistance
will build like armstrong global news
and on the new reality mike takes a
deeper look at what the loss of
education for women in afghanistan will
mean for future generations that's
tomorrow at 7 here on global
thanking the front lines up next the
treats and tributes for canada's health
workers
[Applause]
welcome back here
canada's governor general is starting
off her thanksgiving weekend with a
visit to the ottawa mission mary mae
simon helping to hand out food and hot
meals to the city's most vulnerable the
governor general also took the time to
meet some of the missions clients and
learn more about how they shelter and
support the capital's homeless
population
well we started the pandemic banging
pots and pans in honor of health care
workers now they're more likely to face
abuse from protesters defying public
health measures but as heather urex west
tells us there are still some small acts
of kindness that mean a lot to those on
the front lines of the copic fight
four weeks ago elizabeth prost buried
her dad he didn't die of covet 19 but on
the day of the funeral a coveted
exposure put her mom's care facility
into lockdown robbing her of the chance
to say goodbye i was really really angry
driving back to calgary from
saskatchewan
and i thought well
that's
something
and i thought
what would my dad do what would my dad
do it's amazing thank you so much
instead of being angry she decided she'd
be kind
organizing a morning of treats for
health care workers outside this calgary
hospital people want to do something
they want to express their appreciation
they want to express their love their
gratitude when alberta coveted
restrictions canceled the private events
for calgary's devour catering the
company began selling care packages for
those working in the icu
within days 6 500 meals had been sold a
thousand will be delivered thanksgiving
day the response has been
awe inspiring like i'm i
i am amazed
other gestures have been smaller
colorful signs and costumes to welcome
doctors and nurses coming on shift
a healing jingle dance for those
suffering in the hospital with covert
19. it's a blessing
to everyone who's around us they feel
they feel that power
we ha we try to help uplift the people
who are here or handmade cards created
to spark a smile i just wanted to write
something from the heart
something nice and warming to give the
health
frontline workers a boost of energy when
they read the card for those on the
front lines these kind acts have lifted
spirits it's really nice to see that
despite
um
despite feeling like nobody's listening
clearly there are some people listening
and hearing what we have to say and and
appreciating the work that we're doing
and so it feels really nice with the
fourth wave crisis far from done it's a
bit of fuel for the soul to help health
care workers carry on
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
friday i'm sophie louie tonight's your
canada is a cinnabon forest in winnipeg
thanks for watching far nasser will be
here at the anchor desk tomorrow have a
happy thanksgiving
[Music]